this is a production of cornell
university
thanks rebecca thank you appreciate the
very nice introduction
um all right let me get my laser pointer
here
all right um so again thank you rebecca
um the the work i'm going to present is
my favorite of my whole career
i really enjoyed being involved in
working with an under utilized
species and i'm having a lot of fun with
our community science project
so i'm happy to have this opportunity
today to tell you about how we're
blending both of those
this is a an overview of the points i'll
cover during my presentation i'm going
to start out with some acknowledgements
and tell you about our fiscalist team
i'll then move on to tell you about the
evolution of the project you know how
did we get
started working with the fiscalists i'll
then move on and talk about
characteristics that need improvement
these are
being driven by priorities that we set
in our nsf
proposal but also being generated from
feedback
from our community science group and our
community science project
involves farmers home gardeners and
various organizations and there's
two reasons for this is first you know
we want to get feedback
on the characteristics that need
improvement you know getting that first
hand information
but also we want to familiarize people
with you know what
are ground cherry and golden berry
because i know a lot of people either
haven't heard of them and certainly
haven't had them and then at the end
i'll move on to talk a bit about the
research and how we're fast tracking
that
improvement how we're generating
enhanced germplasm with using gene
editing
i'm not going to go into a lot of detail
on this i gave a talk about this
in february of last year in plant
breeding so this is just going to be
an update on some some new developments
this is our fiscalist team uh this is
our core group this
is esperanza schenstone esperanza headed
up our community science project
this is lynnell randall carrie swartwood
and nathan rheem we're standing in our
field from last year
after right after we got done planting
it
we have some undergraduates in the group
this is mckenna raspantini you'll see
mckenna is using our
backpack shop vac to vacuum up all the
dropped ground cherries in our
greenhouse i'm making
a quicker work of it than what we used
to use a broom and a dustpan
mckenna is a undergrad at tc3 tompkins
county community college
and this is elliott meyer some of you
might know elliott elliott is an
undergrad at
cornell and he's been doing a research
for credit project in our lab
this is savannah dale savannah is a
graduate student from cornell who just
joined our group this year
and this is julie davis julie is
actually a
graduate student in entomology in
jennifer thaler's group
and jennifer is working with tomatillo
which is also a member of the fiscalist
and she's been helping us with some of
our community science and also we're
collaborating with julie and jennifer on
an insect interaction project
so how did we get started working with
the fistulas
well several years ago we were working
with tomato
and my collaborators zach lipman at the
cold spring harbor lab and mike schutz
at johns hopkins university
we're looking at the genes and networks
involved in plant growth habit
fruit characteristics and fluorescence
architecture and tomato
and we're using a primarily a reverse
genetics approach so knocking out gene
expression using crispr
cast to see how it affected the
phenotype
and while we were doing this work we
thought you know wow crispr cast could
be
really a powerful tool for fast tracking
improvement of an underutilized species
and creating this enhanced germplasm
that readers could tap
into to to make those improvements so
for our second round of funding
one of our aims was to take what we
learned
in tomato and apply that to a more
distantly related species
and one that was certainly underutilized
and had very little of any improvement
he decided to stay in the solanaceae
family and this shows a phylogenetic
tree of just some of the solanaceae and
we chose to work with the physilis
and the fissilist that you might be most
familiar with is tomatillo
but we decided to work with ground
cherry and goldenberry and and this is
for two reasons because first we felt
that
you know this would be a great platform
for answering our basic fundamental
research questions looking at the genes
and networks that we've found in tomato
but you know seeing how
they can improve grand cherokee and
goldenberry but we also thought
there was potential for these fruit as
you know specialty fruit crop in the u.s
but definitely after some improvement
now ground cherry you'll sometimes find
in farmers markets
and golden berries you'll sometimes find
in grocery stores
and people often ask me what what do
they taste like and i think they're
expecting them to taste like cherry
tomatoes but
they're much sweeter than cherry
tomatoes and there's a difference
between the ground cherry
and golden berry flavors so ground
cherry is um
is sweet we have one accession from
poland that has a slight pineapple
flavor
but goldenberry is a much more complex
flavor
it's this sweet tart tropical flavor we
have some that have
underlying flavors of mango apricot and
coconut
and kind of a funny story to share i
recently gave someone some golden
berries they had
had ground cherry before and i gave him
some golden berry fruit from the
greenhouse and his reaction was
kapow he just wasn't expecting that
burst of flavor
from the golden berry and it's been fun
because the different accessions we have
have these different flavors
so some characteristics of interest to
us it was that they were
underutilized crops in the u.s they're
more popular in countries such as china
germany and colombia and actually
colombia is the major producer of
goldenberry and this is a picture i took
at tops markets here in ithaca a couple
of years ago
that shows goldenberry in with the other
berries like raspberries and blueberries
so these are grown in colombia but
they're distributed by a company in
florida
they've got good nutritional content
vitamin c beta carotene
they also have anti-inflammatory
antioxidant properties
and the physicists in general are known
for their medicinal properties and this
is certainly true for ground cherry and
goldenberry they've been used over the
centuries
to treat different ailments and they
also contain these compounds for plant
protection these with analytes and
fosalins which are
steroid which have steroidal properties
so these are just some of the germplasm
some of the sources that we've gotten
are germplasm over the years
this is not an exhaustive list just an
example and those that are in these
yellow boxes
are ones that we've worked with the most
over the past several years
as for characteristics that need
improvement i mentioned that you know
some of this is being driven by
priorities in our
nsf project but also feedback that we're
getting from our community scientists
so this is just a list of some of the
improvements that we're hoping to make
um both ground cherry and goldenberry
have this sprawling
unmanageable growth habit requires
supports and trellising which you can
imagine on a larger agricultural scale
is going to involve a lot of labor
for ground cherry it's got a small
marble sized fruit so we would like to
increase the size of that ground cherry
fruit also ground cherry has this fruit
drop problem and that's why it's called
ground cherry
it often drops to the ground before it's
fully ripe and it makes it difficult
with harvesting
but also there is a potential food borne
illness
issue with gathering the fruit up from
the ground and it gets dirty
and just to note that golden berry does
not drop its fruit ground cherry does
but not golden berry
and then there's the husk that surrounds
the fruit
and this can be you know again a labor
issue with having to remove the um husk
for
large-scale production the juices jams
and other food products that they're
used for
and one of the problems with goldenberry
is it's that it's not as productive as
ground cherry it doesn't produce as much
fruit
and we it needs a longer growing season
that's especially true here in the
northeast
so this shows um some plants from our
field last year
um this is about mid-season so sometime
in july
these metal stakes are about seven feet
tall we've sunk them in the ground about
a foot
but you can see how large these plants
are i mean by the end of the season
these plants are to the top
of these steaks we also have to do
trellising
with some twine that we interweave in
between the plants
and excuse me
in between the plants and that's called
floor of the weave
and uh but again you can imagine on a
larger scale this requires a lot of
labor
this shows the plants at the end of near
the end of the season and you can see
how tall they've grown
to the top of those steaks
these are ground ground cherries with
the golden berries in the background
and you can see that they don't grow as
tall but they're sprawling
and we still have to stake and trellis
them so again
it's a lot of work this shows the fruit
size you can see the difference between
the golden berry fruit size here this is
from south africa and this is from india
compared to the ground cherry fruit size
which is much smaller
this is an accession from the
netherlands excuse me and this is from
these are from poland
sorry
and this shows the real you know i
mentioned that we've got this problem
with the fruit drop
and this shows one of our greenhouses
after we've harvested fruit
excuse me so we um
so we use our backpack shop vac but you
can imagine on a larger agricultural
scale
excuse me i don't know what's going on i
was pretty dry in my office i guess
um and um you know farmers would have a
real problem with harvesting these so
the reason for that fruit drop is this
little joint here it's kind of like an
elbow
and the fruit drops in this region um
and what we're doing right now is we're
studying the biology of that region to
try to determine you know how can we fix
that problem we have tried crossing with
goldenberry
but i think there's too much of a
species divergence for it to
be successful at the crosses
so you know how did our community
science project come about
well i felt that if we were thinking
about these as a specialty fruit crop
and doing improvements
i really wanted to hear from
stakeholders from farmers and growers
first hand early in the project to help
guide us through that improvement
but i also felt it was important to
heighten the visibility of this list as
a specialty crop because
you know we didn't want to go through
all this improvement and then spring the
fruit on people and have them say you
know what is this
so i felt it was really important to
have this educational component
as well
so um in 2018 i submitted a proposal to
the triad foundation
and that's a local foundation here in
ithaca um the proposal got funded i was
very excited to have the funding to be
able to do this
i decided to keep it simple and stay
within new york state
and we had 11 farms that were involved
in each of these little red balloons
here
indicates the location of a farm we
provided
um seeds from three different types of
ground cherry and three different types
of golden berry
and in addition to our growers and
farmers we also had 40 participants
that represented home gardeners public
gardens and
we had some plants at the cornell
botanic gardens and also
at the ithaca children's garden summer
camp
we gave people surveys for feedback we
visited the farms
to facilitate communication we had a
facebook page a web page and a blog
and at the end i really wanted to have a
fun event and and bring participants
together
so i work we organized this harvest
celebration event
where people came to share their
experiences and we had some foods made
with
the grand cherry and goldenberry and it
was it really was a lot of fun
so this shows some um images from some
of the farm visits that we made
we um
we gave the farmers some guidance on um
how to grow the plants like how to
germinate the seeds and the distance
they needed to be on space
but we felt that since we weren't paying
them to do this they were doing this
um just out of the goodness the kindness
of their hearts
we wanted them to adopt it into their
production systems
so as you can see this farm here they
put down black plastic
this is a high tunnel operation um this
is another farm where esperanza visited
with the farmer and extension agent and
you can see that these plants are
absolutely gorgeous they did
an amazing job and we got some really
helpful feedback from from our farmers
and growers
so our farms represented farm to table
community supported agriculture
farmers who sold their um fruits and
vegetables at farmers markets and also
wholesale operations there was one farm
in western new york
that grew hundreds of pounds of ground
cherries now that's a lot of ground
cherries when you see how small they are
but they um give them to this fruit they
sell them to this brewing company
and this company makes um a cherry
obscura which is a sour ale
um beer i have yet to get my hands on
this but um
one of these days i will i'm really
dying to give it a try
so for community engagement again we had
home gardeners and public gardeners
public gardens um i absolutely love the
fact that
kids liked growing these plants and they
also
enjoyed eating them you know kids are
tough and
i figured if kids really like them then
we're on the right track for a fun fruit
for them but it's not only the flavor
they enjoy opening them up and and
seeing this little fruit inside
um which is you know just part of um the
experience of eating the ground cherry
and goldenberry
we had um this is signage at the cornell
botanic gardens this was in the heritage
garden if you're familiar with that
and this is um esperanza and our summer
intern kyle
keating visiting with south i think of
children garden summer campers
so they were responsible for growing the
plants taking data
and um sure they shared that data with
um information with esperanza and kyle
so this was you know before 2018 um
actually we had we had only grown these
plants in the greenhouse
um so this was good firsthand
information for how they would do out
in in a field setting so i'm going to
start from the bottom here we had a
couple
of reports from home gardeners about
possible blight and will but really no
disease problems
um chipmunks were the biggest problem
for me in my garden i
never can seem to get a ripe golden
berry or ground cherry
but where um we're really seeing we saw
some
good observations and informations were
with two um
insects the three-lined potato beetle
and this chloridius subflexo
and it wasn't only that we learned about
problems with these but we also learned
about some really
interesting interactions and comparisons
so
for the three-line potato beetle this is
the adult and these are the larvae
so the larva the adults visited the
ground cherry and goldenberry
they laid eggs on both but where we saw
the difference was in larval development
and larval behavior
so on um ground cherries you know
the the eggs would hatch often not not
as many but
we definitely saw an effect on the
larvae they either
didn't develop well or there are only
very few did
but they went to town on the golden
berry we saw
a huge number of larvae on the golden
berry
they did a lot of damage and really the
ground cherry were untouched
kind of similar for clarity subflexo
which is a specialist
insect on the fistulas we saw more of a
problem with goldenberry than we did
with ground cherry
so this shows on the wireless stage of
the chloridia
and this is an image from one of the
farms this is in gibson new york and it
shows one of the stages of the larvae
in this um kind of obliterated fruit
from the insect
um so and some comments that we got i
could i have i could fill slides with
comments that we received from people
i just i just loved um getting all the
information from them
um so for grindel cherry
excuse me this is a comment from one of
the growers he said that if you could
get these plants to behave meaning no
food drop and less sprawling we'd be
into acres of these so this is the first
time
that they had grown um this ground
cherry
fruit um and then i also excuse me
have had a few people ask when they were
gonna get the
gene edited lines when would they be
available
for instance we had one organic farmer
here in ithaca
who wasn't interested in growing ground
cherry again because he said he had
grown them in the past and they were
just too much work but he'd be happy to
give the gene edited lines a try which
was
great to hear and another um
story to share is that there is a
project participant
in minnesota her name is betty
and betty doesn't have internet access
she doesn't
do online but she's called me a number
of times over the years she found out
about the project through
an article in a magazine or newspaper um
and she called me one day earlier this
year
and said now joyce um the seeds you gave
us they're not from the gene edited
material
in the gene edited plants and i said oh
you know and i thought oh my goodness
she's concerned that we have given them
gene edited material i said oh
no betty you know these are all the
unimproved lines we just want feedback
from people to know how we can improve
them
and she said oh i really something like
i really want to give the gene edited
lines a try because
i've grown ground cherry for many years
and they're really a problem so whenever
the gene edited lines are available
please share them with me
um so that was um it was really good to
hear that there was um
not too much concern on betty's part
about having these gene edited lines
as far as flavor um i've got some good
feedback on flavor
and this one person said that they you
know the ground this is gb means
goldenberry was amazing
um and very different from ground cherry
and again this is on these last two
comments point to the problems with the
beetles
um this one person said that the potato
beetles definitely prefer golden berries
which substantiates some of the other
other observations that we we got
and one of my favorite comments was this
one i have never fought so hard for a
crop
and the three lime potato beetles were
relentless so again
you know really good feedback for us
that you know originally when we put in
our nsf project we're thinking about
agronomic characteristics such as plant
growth habit
and fruit size but we started to learn
about
insect problems as well from this first
year of our community science project
this is on a screenshot of our website
and blog
if you're interested in taking a look
it's called the fistless improvement
project so if you do a search for that
you'll find it
you can subscribe to the blog and we
also have twitter accounts i um
post information often about the project
on my twitter account and then we have
this just list project account as well
so for our harvest celebration event we
invited participants we had foods that
were prepared with the fistulas we had a
let me see we had a
ground cherry rice pudding we had these
little muffins that had ground cherries
on the top
i made a granola with dried golden
berries that i got the dried golden
berries off amazon
we also asked people to share their
experiences with growing it
every event that we do we take our
whiteboard and some
post-it notes to ask people to come up
with the name for the ground cherry
because when we fix that fruit drop
problem we're not going to call it
ground cherry anymore
so these are two suggestions we also had
activities for kids
and we gave these mugs out as thank you
gifts
so it was a great event we had a lot of
fun and we decided
that we would do this again in the
following year
so in 2019 i had some carryover funding
from the triad
and i used that preliminary information
from the triad
to apply for an nsf supplement and i got
that
so we felt that since we were a success
in new york state that we could expand
um into other states so we ended up with
70 participants in 18 different states
indicated by each of these blue balloons
we this year we made some connections
with chefs we took fruits for chefs
to chefs to be able to have them come up
with some dishes because we felt that
if chefs wanted it then they would ask
farmers to grow them and this was a
great outreach for consumers who maybe
had never heard or tried ground cherry
or goldenberry
we also did a consumer panel evaluation
that i'll tell you about
on the next couple slides julie went to
the farmer's market
to do a taste testing
and um esperanza and mckenna again
visited with our next group of summer
campers at the ithaca children's garden
so for um consumer panel evaluation we
did this in collaboration with cornell
sensory evaluation center
right here on campus we had to
limit it to a hundred participants we
ended up with 102 and they each
got five dollars this shows
mckenna and esperanza in the kitchen of
the evaluation center
you can see all the fruit they prepared
and then there are these metal shoots
here
that they put the fruit on a tray and
pass it to the participants on the other
side
each different type of fruit had a
number associated with it so it was a
lot of work in preparing this
the evaluation center personnel told us
to keep it simple
so we had just two types of ground
cherry and two types of golden berry
there were 22 questions for the
participants to answer with 11
qualifiers like
i like it extremely i like it very much
etc
we also had a comment section in
addition to flavor
we asked people if they would like it
with it without the husk and we got some
information about
color and size preferences and also
about seediness
and there were these additional
questions that we asked people to
complete
and after all this i was thinking wow
you know that's a lot to ask people i
wonder if paying them five dollars is
really enough i mean i certainly
felt especially after seeing the results
that they deserved more than five
dollars
so this um this shows right here down in
the bottom right hand corner the
participants on the other side of the
kitchen
they are answering the questions on the
computer when they need the next round
of fruit
they um there's a little button they can
push and then
esperanza would put the fruit on the
tray and and feed it through to the
participants
this is great really to see behind the
scenes of how these this taste testing
these evaluations are done
so just we got a ton of data back but
i'm just including some quick takeaways
here
so 53 percent had never tried ground
terry or goldenberry so a great way to
familiarize people about
you know what they are we um found that
um
75 percent um preferred the ground
cherry flavor for golden berry
and then there were some preferences for
um
golden you know within the golden berry
itself
now columbia is the one that we got from
the tops market and saved the seeds and
grew those up in the field
um we knew that they really didn't taste
all that great um so we just kind of
wanted to see what
we didn't think so we wanted to see a
consumer's thought and they agreed
so i was really happy to hear that 82
percent of people of the participants
would actually purchase them
um an interesting result was that 60
percent of people prefer to have it with
the husk and the comments were that
um they was more natural more closer to
what the fruit you know
actually was naturally and it was fun to
open up the husk and and see the fruit
but there were some concerns that you
know do we know are we going to find
mold or insect
in the fruit which does just happen
sometimes
and something that i was really
surprised about was that seediness was
not a problem there are a lot of seeds
in these fruit
and i thought people might have an issue
with it but but they didn't
as far as size um there's a golden
bearing ground cherry
we found overall that people felt that
the ground cherry was too small
but india was too big colombia was just
right so now we know for our improvement
purposes
is to really get somewhere close or
right on with the columbia size
we also got some feedback on color and
we're using all of this information now
from the consumer evaluation again to
help guide our improvements
of ground sharing goldenberry so this
year
we got close to 1400 seed requests i'll
talk a little bit more about that in the
next slide
but basically this was a result of an
article in the la
los angeles times in the la times i gave
uh
one of the writers talked to me about
the project and we ended up getting a
huge response
we had to cap it at 750 participants
because of the amount of seeds we had
we ended up with 43 different states
represented
and my goal was to have somebody in
alaska and hawaii and we actually had
some participants in those two states as
well so
i really um really happy to see that you
know everything
we got really great buy-in on to the
project in addition to individuals we
ads also had
various organizations involved in the
project this year
and some of the comments we got back was
that it was great to have
a project like this during this coven
doing the pandemic to
kind of help keep people's minds off
things for a while and have something
interesting
um to do and to participate in a project
so going back to that article in the la
times we
there an online version of the story
came out in early january
and we ended up um with a lot of
requests at that point
and then the editors liked the story so
much that they asked that they could put
it in print and
so they did so we had another article
come out in print
this was in february of this year so
esperanza was getting really worried
especially after the online article
she she took the request and graphed it
so here's showing the graph on versus
months versus number of participants
and you can see before the article came
out we were around 150 participants
and then after the online article came
out we were up in the 600s
again esperanza was worried about the
print version coming out and i said oh
don't worry who reads print versions of
newspapers these days
all of our requests are going to come
from online well i was
wrong because we ended up getting a huge
spike in request after the paper
the print version came out we had to
shut down the request site
and our business office told me that the
phones ended up burning as they said
with people calling to get seeds
esperanza and i each got emails and i
even after that got
letters from people asking to be part of
the project so um really it was
overwhelming to see on how people wanted
to be involved and wanted to help out
with the project
so this just shows one container of
envelopes that we sent out seeds
and we ended up um with over 800
subscribers to our project blog so a
great way to be able to
educate people about grand cherry and
golden berry
we're using eye naturalists this year
to help gather all that information
we're focusing on the three-line potato
beetle but we've also asked people to
take pictures and include information of
other insects or just of their plants in
general
so the way this works is they can take a
picture it comes with an identifier this
shows a three-line potato beetle
we can look at the observations we can
look at the pictures and we can also
graph this in our data from this year
this is just some other data that
esperanza included
in the slide to show an example of how
we can graph all of that data
um so we were the project
naturalist ends on the end of this month
and then we'll go in and
take a look and graph all that data
so again our primary information we want
it was on insects but we also asked
people to gather information
on other characteristics as we did in
previous years
we included a blog series this year on
crop improvement
so each time that we have a posting
it's about a different aspect of crop
improvement so we started out with plant
breeding
we had one on mutation breeding and this
is here so this is a more recent one
that savannah
dale put together on genome sequencing
and how that's part of crop improvement
we'll eventually work our way through up
getting up to
gene editing as well
i really wanted to expand connections
with chefs this year but because of
covid
that made it really difficult almost
impossible
but i really wanted to show the public
what could be done with these so i
thought
oh i know zoe dubrow in
plant mythology and zoe is an amazing um
baker i i follow her on twitter and i
saw some of the um just gorgeous
desserts that she she would make in post
so i i asked zoe if she was interested
in um giving our ground cherries a try
we had a lot of ground cherries at that
time
earlier in the season and if she would
write a blog for us
about about what she created so you can
see
this here is a tart that she made with
ground cherry curd it's absolutely
beautiful
she made these are a french
little cake that she learned about when
she was doing some research in france
um and plants not in baking but she um
learned about these i think they're
called financiers i probably have
slaughtered that name
but she put the ground cherry in that
and and had the husk
up at the top here she also grant um
dried the ground cherries and made
scones and used that ground cherry curd
she posted this information on instagram
she got a lot of hits i followed some of
the comments people asking where they
could get ground cherry and goldenberry
and and if you're interested go to our
website
zoe's got links to her recipes
on that post and we also have recipes on
that site for some of the
dishes that were part of our harvest to
them
so to summarize this part of the project
and and where are we going um
you know this has been as i mentioned
earlier so much fun
and just i'm just so happy to see how
people really want to help us
um i want to i need to write proposals
get more funding
we're kind of on a pause right now
because agencies that i wanted to apply
for for funding
um for outreach type um
initiatives were not taking proposals
this year
i had funding for esperanza only until
june of this year she's moved on to
another position so i really need to get
some more funding to get somebody in to
help with this
in the future i want to expand our
number of farm to table and csas connect
more with local chefs and
on some other ideas that we might be
able to come up with so if anybody has
any ideas of where i could apply for
funding
for some outreach and this kind of
community science i'd be happy to hear
about it
so now i'm going to move on and just
give you a bit of information about some
of the um
lab work research that we're doing and
how this is being guided by our
community science um
information and also some of our own
priorities
so we're fast tracking this improvement
gene editing um
you know part of it is that to create
enhanced germplasm
that has variability that breeders could
tap into
for improvement programs but before we
do the gene editing the first place we
had to start
was in developing a transformation
method and we started with ground cherry
because ground cherries are diploid
goldenberry is a
tetraploid and we felt with editing
diploid would be a much easier one to
tackle first so we base this on our
tomato transformation method
so we put ground cherry seeds in culture
they germinate
a difference between this and our tomato
method is that for tomato the cotyledons
are the explant
that works the best but for grand cherry
we found hypocotyls actually regenerate
plants
um that cod leads do not so that's a big
difference between tomato and ground
cherry
this is just our regeneration scheme
this isn't transformation
the medium contains growth regulators
that induces callusing in shoots
we then get plants that root um we take
cuttings and they're put into a test
tube
and the fully rooted plants are then
evaluated for
genotype with their genotype to look for
edits
when we have those rooted plants and
they've been genotyped if they're what
we're looking for they get transferred
to soil
we cover them with these water bottles
i've had the bottoms cut off
help us gradually acclimate those plants
to the real world because they've been
in these very humid culture vessels
we um take the caps off after a few days
and then completely remove the bottle
after about a week and you can see how
those plants transition
really well it's basically it's almost
like it's a hundred percent going from
tissue culture to soil for us
this is the vector system we've been
using we started using this
with tomato it's got this cassette here
with the npt2
um gene that confers resistance to the
antibiotic anamycin
we include the cannabis in in our
culture medium to select for only those
cells that received this vector
we have the cas9 being driven by the 35s
constitutive promoter
and our guide rnas are driven by the
arabidopsis eu6 polymerase promoter
now you can see we use two guide rnas
you really only need one guide rna
if it's working well to get edits but
because we were doing a reverse genetics
approach we really wanted to slam
expression
so we're using two guide rnas spaced
about 50 to 100 base pairs apart
but over time what we found is even
though we follow
all the rules for designing guide rnas
sometimes one works and the other one
doesn't so by including two guide rnas
for gene we actually can kind of save
ourselves time
we then take this vector we
electroporate it into agrobacterium
and we do the transformation experiment
for our editing scheme we added those
first lines which i'm calling
e0 and instead of t0 which is actually
often used for transgenic lines but
since the um
this helps us separate what our over
expression transgenic lines are
from our edited set so we genotype those
e0's for
edits we transfer them to the greenhouse
we then pcr that e1 generation
for cast nine we only want to move
plants forward that are
casino negative that have just the
mutation or the edits
we um then you know do the same
for the e2 plants we genotype them for
edits and
you know all along here we're looking at
the phenotype but it isn't until we get
to the later generations where we start
to take a deeper evaluation of the
phenotype
sometimes we have to go back to the
drawing board and choose a different
gene to edit
um but then when they then they reach a
point where we feel
we feel really good about that phenotype
we'll cross it with wild type evaluate
it some more
and genotype it as well so again just
generating this um
you know these edits to see what's going
to make the difference and and
what we see as a good phenotype that
carries through
several generations now as for the
targeted traits of interest again
this is just going to be brief compared
to maybe other
presentations where i would talk about
the work so i'm going to focus
just on one gene that we've targeted for
plant growth habit and there are a
number of genes that we have tried but
this is the one that we have
kind of the most history with this is
self pruning or sp
so self pruning is an uh flowering
repressor
and if you grow tomatoes you know that
there are these
indeterminate types that grow really
unmanageable and large
and then there are the determinant types
well the determinant types
are because of this mutation in sp
and it was back in the late 1920s that a
grower
saw this compact tomato in his field and
over time it was determined that it was
a mutation in this sp they have this
determinate growth habit
and burst of early flowering and
breeders took this material
and started to put it into their
commercial lines and it really
revolutionized
commercial tomato production well we
found that counterpart in ground cherry
this sequence up here is the wild type
sequence and these are what our guide
rnas look like
and then our edit this is just some of
our edited lines and you can see where
those edits happened
um in both of those guide rnas this
shows the phenotype of just one of our
lines here you can see this is the wild
type how tall it is compared to the
edited lines
if you're interested in reading more
about this and some of the other genes
that uh
that we've edited for playing for
different characteristics we had a
publication back in 2018 so again you
know following through looking at the
next generation and seeing if this is
the type of gene that is going to give
us what we want in later generations
or if we need to go back and look at
something else
for fruit size just like plant growth
habit there are a number of genes but
i'm going to tell you about this clavata
one
so clavata1 works in concert with wishel
to keep shoot meristem
maintenance normal and so you can
imagine that a loss of function
would cause an increase in the size of
shoot and floral meristem
and the first um sign that this was
actually working
in our ground cherry lines was that in
the wild type ground cherry
the petals the flowers have five petals
but in our crisper lines we had
up to seven petals on those flowers we
saw
a 24 increase in fruit weight in the
edited lines
we also saw an increase in locul numbers
so locules are those little compartments
that hold
the seeds wild types had two locules and
the edited lines have three locules
the sequence down here again this is the
wild type it shows you
on what that sequence looked like and as
i mentioned before you know sometimes
one guide rna works and the other one
doesn't
well that was certainly true in this
case for a guide rna one we didn't get
any edits
um the guide rna2 did give us edits and
that was enough for us to be able to see
a difference in fruit size in these
lines
so two experiments that are at the early
stage are those
to address this fruit drop issue and
abscission
and also insect interactions
so this is work that's being done by
nathan rheem in the group
as i mentioned earlier the fruit drops
because of this little
this region here we tried crossing with
golden berry um it didn't work
so we've done rna seek of this joint
region at different stages
of development early middle and late and
right now nathan is plowing through
all this data to try to determine some
targets that we could try
now you know to me some tomatoes do
produce a joint
but they don't drop their fruit so i'm
imagining there is a different mechanism
that's involved in the joint and
abscission in tomato
versus ground cherry and also we did
target some of the genes that have been
reported and that we've seen responsible
for joint and tomato
but they didn't work in the ground
cherry so this rna-seq
information is going to be really
helpful for us to try to determine
how to move forward for the
insect interactions again this came
about because of our community science
work
um i mentioned those differences between
ground cherry and goldenberry
that it appeared that the golden berry
was more affected by both the
three-lined potato beetle
and the chlorina subflexa than the
ground cherry and actually the
three-lined potato beetle preferred the
fistulas
over potato it was the first time i grew
uh ground cherry and goldenberry in my
garden was the first time i had these
beautiful looking potato plants because
all the three-lined potato beetles went
to the ground cherry and goldenberry
but they definitely prefer the golden
berry
i um again i submitted a proposal to the
triad foundation to get some preliminary
information
um that we could we could use to go
after
a larger grant for this work we
started by doing an unbiased metabolic
metabolic profiling
of this material right now we've
completed it for leaves we're looking at
husks and fruit
as well we're using lcms and we're doing
three accessions each of
ground cherry and goldenberry this is
work again being done by
nathan rheem and we're collaborating
with frank schroeder's group and this
is bennett fox who is a postdoc in
frank's group
for the ground cherry we're using this
zl05 which is a line we got from the
netherlands um
g.o is goldie it's one that's available
through
johnny's select seeds and this is the
pineapple which is one of our accessions
from poland
and the golden berries is india south
africa and colombia
so just in brief um for the method we're
using a freeze-dried material
that we then extract and then we run
that on the lcms
these are two chromatograms showing the
differences between ground cherry and
goldenberry i mean that just what i want
you to take from this is very visual
and looking at the differences in the
number of peaks and the height of the
peaks
but please note that there are
differences in scale here so you can see
there's definitely a difference in these
metabolite profiles between the ground
cherry and goldenberry
nathan then took that information and
generated this heat map
and the way i interpret this is that
those
in yellow are the most abundant and each
line
represents a different metabolite
feature so you can see globally that
with the ground cherry versus golden
berry there are definitely differences
in the types and the amount of
metabolites
and there are also um differences in
between each different type within
ground cherry and goldenberry
so we're taking this information doing a
deeper dive
and doing leaf bioassays as well in
collaboration with
jennifer and julie and entomology
so to summarize on this part of the talk
you know
crispr has been a really valuable tool
we were able to make those modifications
that i mentioned for the sp
and covada in just two years um we're
moving into goldenberry we have our
first edited lines of goldenberry in the
greenhouse
we're going to expand on that work with
fruit drop and abscission
for our metabolites we're focusing on
with analytes
with analytes right now because they've
been reported to be
involved in insect interactions in the
fistulas and we're doing some metabolic
engineering to create mutants to help us
tease apart
which with analytes might be involved
and with that um
i'd like to thank our farmers community
scientists in public gardens
i mentioned my group earlier bennett and
fox involved in the metabolite work
our greenhouse group for all their
patients with all that drop fruit
kristoff jennifer and julie are involved
in the insect and metabolite work
zach and mike i mentioned earlier and
our funding agencies
who've made this all possible and i want
to thank you for attending
and i'm happy to take questions now
well joyce thank you so much for a
really wonderful
journey through your work on fissileness
that was absolutely delightful
and very impressive to um realtor to
force from participatory research to
successful editing and domestication and
can you please add me to your
list of extremely large numbers of
people who want seed i
i enjoy in my years in peru i um
the golden berry even now if i get a you
know a packet
i mean a basket of either one of those
pups at the farmer's market i just eat
it
once annoying my family members because
i'm eating them by the time they get
anywhere so uh yeah like questions
please any questions or comments
isabella is your is your um
are you there for for a question
okay just being friendly thank you who's
got a question oh let me look at the
chat we've got a few chats in here um
yeah brennan can you go ahead
yeah i can i guess i can ask it um
yeah so what was the the demographic
distribution
of like the people you engaged in your
community science project
so you know it sounds like you're able
to recruit people
across all different states but sort of
what was you know the differences in
like cultural backgrounds living
environments
you know incomes uh just because it'd be
interesting to see how that would vary
across different demographics right
yeah more groups are more engaged with
this novel
fruit than others yeah that's a great
question
and it's not something we have that
information on at this point i mean we
were just
kind of focusing on getting people
involved and educating people but it's
not something that we
have tracked but i think it's a great
suggestion for something that we should
track going forward
for sure so i'm not really sure how we
might get that information
now if you have any suggestions on how
we might do that
we have our map and we show the
different locations and we
we can go in and um track where people
are located
like where they you know because we've
got the information about where they
live
um but again it's not something that we
we've tracked
but a good idea um
there's a couple of pieces of fan mail
from jalook and mark
so just to fyi maybe to that similar to
brennan's question i would like to ask
um is there some way in which the people
in the testing network your
participatory network
are they kind of related to each other
like are they aware of what each other
are saying
and could there at some point be
questions about you know what's our
demographic
structure and you know who are we and
you know who's like you or who's not
like you know like just some way that
you can socially network
yeah one of our participants this year
actually suggested and i can't remember
what it was but she accept she suggested
an application that we could use
to indeed do that sort of thing um to
have people interact and get more of
that information and that's something
that we would use going forward i saved
that email
and will be using i just can't remember
what it was called
um greg go ahead um gregory vogel
got a question up there yeah thank you
for the
really interesting talk i was wondering
if you could talk a little bit about the
reproductive biology of these
fissal species and in particular if
they self-pollinate or outcross and if
there's any self-incompatibility
they um they do self
um and um
there is a small different species not
the ones that we're working with
um in general but there are other
fistula species that do have some level
of outcrossing that happens
and as far as incompatibility we haven't
with at least with the
types that we've been working with
ground cherry and goldenberry we haven't
had a problem
but we have done some work with
tomatillo and some of the tomatillos
definitely have a self-incompatibility
problem
so what we've done there is we've
recommended that people and there is
some outcrossing with tomatillo
we've recommended that people plant the
you know two different
couple of different types and more than
just one plant
in order to get some fruit for those so
we would have to do crosses with the
tomatillo in the greenhouse to get fruit
on some of them but not all of them it
was just certain
tomatillos that we had a problem with
um over to you isabelle
yeah so i do actually have a question um
so i was wondering in the sensory study
that
your lab conducted um were there any
like com
commonly mentioned flavors that people
like disliked just because i
um i tried ground cherries a long time
ago when i was
freshman i think um and have since made
a whole bunch of my friends try them
because i've gotten them from the
farmer's market
and a lot of them actually said that
they got this weird tomato like
aftertaste
that they weren't a huge fan of but i
wonder if that if any
other flavors popped up yeah we had this
really
cool wheel that they generated with all
the information that people
talked about different flavors that they
had this gorgeous color
wheel that i didn't show today that
helped us like
under you know the chocolate or laundry
detergent or
you know kind of other some other things
and we kind of
so we kind of threw in that columbia one
as a ringer because
you know i don't know there's probably
some sort of agronomic reason why
they've chosen to distribute that one um
at least through sun bell
but it tastes awful it's got this
terrible aftertaste it was my first time
tasting golden berry i was really
excited and i tasted i was like oh this
is horrible
but since that time we've gotten
accessions from other places that are
absolutely delicious and they don't have
that aftertaste
as some do so it really depends on the
type that you're working with and what
we see we have one that is um
from austria called sherburne gold and
it's got this apricot flavor and it's
it's just has none of that aftertaste
that you might find in some of the other
sessions especially like the one from
columbia
thank you
if you'd like me to share that wheel of
all the flavors with you i can show i
can share that slide if you shoot me an
email
if you're interested that would be
awesome yeah i i've i took a couple of
classes on coffee and cacao and it would
be really interesting to see one for
fruit
oh sure i'll send you the listen to the
whole presentation information
thank you well uh
if there are any other questions um step
up now
if not we're at time anyway so um
i want to agree end by just maybe
reading joel luke's comment which i'm
thankful fantastic
[Laughter]
thank you so much that was really
inspiring and fantastic and
um i look forward to you know if yeah
joyce again if you have any extra fruit
or seeds you know
i'll
thank you so much thanks everybody bye
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu